last night Ron DeSantis the Republican
governor of Florida
was brutalized by Challenger Charlie
Christ to the point where at one at
multiple moments during the debate
DeSantis appeared to be malfunctioning
his brain looked like it was
malfunctioning he didn't know what to
say and in some cases didn't say
anything this is Wild Charlie Crist is
almost certainly going to lose to Rhonda
Sanders now losing by about 10 points in
Florida but this was one of the best
performances by Charlie Crist of any
2022 candidate let's get right into it
now by the way before as we jump in
even many of the topics
were topics that it's sort of a joke
that they were even being discussed
critical race Theory
um talking about the fact that trans
people exist the the very existence of
these issues rather than substantive
issues of actual relevance uh it already
shows the degree to which the right has
dominated the framing and has shifted
the Overton window to the absurd but
let's put that aside for a second Ron
DeSantis doesn't like the approach that
some schools are taking because he says
it teaches that the U.S was built on
Stolen Land wait a second wasn't it it
actually if you look around the country
they do have programs unfortunately well
they will take a student look at their
race say okay you're white you're an
oppressor if you're black you're
oppressed and think about what that does
to a six or seven-year-old kid that's
wrong you're seeing that you have people
that are teaching and actually his
running mate has said this in the past
that teaching the United States was
built on Stolen land that is
inappropriate for our schools it's not
true and I'm happy can you imagine now
it it's not unique like it's
we live in the U.S so a lot of history
that's taught to kids is U.S history you
know in other countries interestingly
enough
kids are taught more global history but
okay put that aside for a second it's
the U.S so kids are taught us history
it's not unique that the U.S now exists
on what we would accurately call stolen
land I mean countries in 2022 are on
land that was stolen won by War
annexed purchased or created by
International treaty it's not really a
special thing it's not unique to the
United States the Roman Empire the Zulu
Empire the Mongol Empire you look at the
history of how Japan came to be what it
is it's all a combination of these few
mechanisms it's not special
it's not a unique pejorative to teach
the reality these people live in a
fantasy world now what became a very big
issue during yesterday's debate and
Charlie Chris handled it very well
Charlie Crist pointed out multiple times
DeSantis is angling to run for president
will he commit to actually serving out
his four-year gubernatorial term and
each time DeSantis was more and more
flustered by it very very interesting
let's take a look Ron you talk about Joe
Biden a lot I understand you think
you're going to be running against him I
can see how you might get confused but
you're running for governor you're
running for governor and I have a
question for you you're running for
governor why don't you look in the eyes
of the people of State of Florida and
say to them if you're re-elected you
will serve a full four-year term as
Governor yes or no
[Applause]
yes or no this is the point at which it
looks like desantis's brain is
malfunctioning will you serve a full
four-year term if you're re-elected
governor of Florida
it's not a tough question
it's a fair question he won't tell you
we did not agree on the candidates
asking each other's Governor it's your
turn well listen I know that Charlie is
interested in talking about 2024 and Joe
Biden but I just want to make things
very very clear the only worn out old
donkey I'm looking to put out to pasture
is Charlie Chris so there of course uh
Chris about 20 something years older
than Ron DeSantis and Ron DeSantis going
in that direction but this really didn't
get any better uh it continued and it
was it was quite ugly and telling about
Ron DeSantis when we worn out old donkey
I'm looking to put out the pasture is
Charlie Chris
yeah well Ron we know you love to bully
people and the little name calling you
just exchanged I can take it but you
shouldn't do it when children are
standing behind you at a press
conference and they're wearing a mask
true
but apparently Chris did very very well
in this debate I don't know that it will
actually be enough to make a difference
but it was quite a scene because you
like having it as an issue for political
scoring in points that you want to have
for a future campaign and let me remind
the viewers he wouldn't even answer you
if he would stay four years if you
re-elect him as your Governor you're
running for governor you're asking them
to vote for you for governor at a
minimum you ought to be able to tell
them if you get reelected you'll serve
as governor Ron Governor so we had the
border that was in much better shape in
January of 2021 and the audience really
noticing he does not want to answer that
question because he obviously is getting
set up to run for president then the
topic of abortion came up Ron DeSantis
said he's proud of the 15-week abortion
ban that Florida passed and he wrongly
claims that at 15 weeks babies are full
fully formed I'm proud of the 15 weeks
that we did I know Charlie Crist opposes
that even though the baby is fully
formed has a heartbeat can feel pain and
can suck their thumb he also supports
set selective abortions that was
someone's screaming liar he used to
discriminate against little girls he
supports dismemberment abortions where
they literally will tear the baby limb
from Limb and he supports taxpayer
funding of abortion all the way up until
the moment of birth and that is wrong
yeah now understand that there is debate
over what fully formed means certainly
there is no viability at 15 weeks but
the truth is that it's actually
irrelevant to the debate and what I mean
by that is the following do you think
for a second if it was proven to the
extent that it could be proven that a
fetus is not fully formed by any
definition at 15 weeks do you think
people like DeSantis would all of a
sudden go oh you know what
now that we've determined the fetus
isn't fully formed at 15 weeks I'm okay
with abortion no of course not that's
the trick that it doesn't actually
matter to them they are just coming up
with whatever they can say to justify
increasingly Draconian abortion
restrictions the crowd wasn't loving it
um at another moment the topic of
business came up
Charlie Chris doing an excellent job of
flipping around who is pro-business on
DeSantis who claims to be a very
pro-business Republican Chris was very
well prepared I'm pro-business I want to
make sure we keep our businesses open
I'm not the governor who attacked Walt
Disney World because they Dame to
express their point of view
I'm not the governor who attacked the
cruise industry because they just wanted
to make sure that their customers
weren't sick before they got on the boat
that's you you're the most anti-business
Governor I've ever seen
DeSantis was increasingly annoyed and
interestingly
um he he had this attitude sort of
similar actually to Marco Rubio in his
debate last week that even having to be
there is sort of beneath him he seemed
resentful that he even had to debate the
topic of the Martha's Vineyard flights
came up remember this stunt wherein uh
Marco I'm sorry not Marco Rubio Ron
DeSantis paid to fly migrants from Texas
to Martha's Vineyard
um and again Christ was very well
prepared State congressman
I thought what the governor did was a
horrible political stunt
um you know we have an immigration
problem we have a problem at the border
we need to secure the Border I agree
with all of that but it doesn't mean
that you use Florida taxpayers dollars
to Charter two jets go to Texas lie to
people to get them onto planes fly them
up to the northern part of our country
and and one of them's a one-year-old
baby
another is a pregnant woman
you're willing to use people like that
in this case they were Hispanics
Venezuelan in particular
and have them as props for your
political gain that's not the way to
change policy you can change policy and
do what's right to secure the porter by
having comprehensive immigration reform
that's what I voted for in Congress when
you're in Congress you wouldn't do it
because you want to keep this issue
alive you want to have it as a wedge
issue and you want to pull political
stunts like you did with the taxpayers
dollars of the people of Florida that's
not what it's for that's not what you
should have done it isn't funny it's not
right and you we're inhumane and how you
treated these people and DeSantis really
didn't have any substantive rebuttal it
was just sort of like well you know we
have a real problem and the Chris Biden
border crisis and blah blah blah blah
blah last thing here when Ron DeSantis
tried to close out the debate claiming
he led the pandemic response based on
facts someone very succinctly in the
audience just yells out liar which is of
course an accurate criticism when a once
in a century pandemic hit I led based on
facts not based on
right so a disastrous debate for Rhonda
santis but I hate to tell you it
probably will not make a difference if
you live in Florida you should vote
there's no doubt about it it is right
now a 10 point deficit a 10-point
deficit for Charlie Crist Charlie Crist
would be a fine governor for Florida
Ronda santis is a disaster he is using
this to set up his presidential run if
it's convenient if it ends up going that
way without a doubt really good debate
for Charlie Crist DeSantis fumbling and
looking malfunctioning almost trump-like
glitches but DeSantis sadly will
probably win but maybe not let's all
vote remember that we have a YouTube
channel approaching 2 million
subscribers I found out an incredible
piece of data last week my colleague
John told me this even though
we had four and a half million different
people watch videos on our YouTube
channel last month
only about one and a half million are
subscribed there are three million
viewers on YouTube who watch our Clips
but aren't subscribed make sure you hit
that subscribe button because it is so
important for the algorithm and for
signaling to YouTube that our content is
engaging enough for people to want to
subscribe there are three million of you
out there and I am speaking to you today
make sure to join the ranks of our
YouTube subscribers it's free we will
take a quick break and be back right
after this
I want to tell you about something I use
every day because it simplifies my life
I don't have hours to mathematically
plan every meal or take multiple
different supplements and vitamins to
make sure I'm getting exactly what I
want to get every single day and the
solution is our sponsor athletic greens
product ag1 I've been taking ag1 for
over a year it's just great it's just
one small scoop of ag1 in the morning I
get 75 vitamins minerals probiotic all
from whole food sources it's what I want
it's no more it's no less it's no
extraneous stuff making wild claims I
drink it straight with water because I
like the taste you can put it in a
smoothie or juice or a shake it's just
simple ag1 is a sustainable routine
because it's just one scoop in the
morning takes one minute once a day I
know I'm covered in getting what I want
I can really be sure that I am properly
nourishing my body with the things I'm
trying to get that's the most important
part athletic greens knows I'm a vitamin
D guy I've talked about in the winter I
take vitamin D to make up for the lack
of sun exposure I take that every day as
well I've mentioned it on the show and
so athletic greens is giving you a free
year of vitamin D and five free travel
packs with your first purchase when you
go to athleticgreens.com Pacman the link
is down below